[Music]
so we don't have enough truck drivers
that's part of the so-called supply
chain problem of course the cause is
we've acted like driving a truck was
somehow a disreputable thing to do and
majoring in gender studies was like the
greatest thing you can do so we're
obviously reaping the fruits of that but
msnbc is a completely different
explanation for you'll be shocked to
learn that according to a host called
tiffany cross
the real problem is racism according
tiffany cross too many truck drivers are
the wrong color watch
this is again an industry populated um
by a lot of white men over the age of
55.
this group of people overwhelmingly
voted for trump um some people have
talked about you know aggressive truck
drivers cutting them off or not being
helpful
so if if you think the supply chain
problem is the result of racism
maybe you've got a certain obsession
that's
coloring your interpretation so to speak
all of this was kind of interesting news
to carl tharp porter he's a truck driver
called carl from the south side we saw
his response to that segment on twitter
here's what he wrote quote i'm a truck
driver doesn't matter that i'm black and
i've never experienced racism from other
drivers don't bring your leftist agenda
to us
so we thought it'd be kind of
interesting to talk to an actual truck
driver which carl thorpe porter is and
we're happy to have him join us right
now carl thanks so much for coming on
um
so
msnbc's view is that this is somehow a
race crisis
that our trucking shortage is that your
experience as a truck driver
not at all um i want to say that there
is a divide but it's not on the issues
of race
um i've had to do my due diligence as
far as talking to
the elder experienced truck drivers um
that are so-called black and i had to
ask them you know have you experienced
these things like
is being interpreted
and
the obvious is that
a lot of people are dealing with
emotional issues here um it's more of an
accountability issue
it's a spiritual battle and i think that
it's either right or wrong good or evil
and that's how i look at it i like to
look at things in that type of lens i
don't fall into the the prey of the left
where it goes more of the emotional base
and it plays upon your emotional
weariness as far as being fearful of
things to happen
what struck me was that
the woman stated that there was a racism
issue but she didn't talk about the more
important issues like of gender being in
the field of drug driving as a woman um
that we deal with wage issues we deal
with dot regulation issues the fact that
i have to be over the road for over two
weeks and then come back home and i see
my family those are true issues i don't
want to deal with the
invisible boogey man like racism so to
be able to talk about this tucker i
appreciate you and um i just want to get
that word out that we need to get over
this imaginary thought of racism to me
it doesn't exist again it's only good
and evil right and wrong
truckers that do things that are wrong
out there you need to take
accountability and let those people know
that that's not the way that we do
things we are a family unit in the truck
driving industry we don't want to deter
young drivers like myself away from the
industry because of other people's fears
and disbeliefs
yeah so in other words the real problem
truck driving is it's a hard job
you know it's harder than your family
once you get paid more yeah exactly
maybe they could point that out once in
a while
yeah i bet well thank you for doing it
because we need it carl thorpe porter
good to see you tonight
all right now take care hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else